in the midst of the metoo hysteria when
everyone was fixating on Aziz ansari's
bad date and Brett Kavanaugh's Phantom
gang rape trains researchers at Morgan
Stanley had a very different Focus they
were concerned as you might imagine
about the financial ramifications of the
modern feminist movement so they sent an
analysis to their corporate clients
looking into the economic impact of this
new wave of feminism that was overtaking
the country and here was their Top Line
conclusion by 2030 Morgan Stanley wrote
more than 45 percent of working women
aged 25 to 44 in the United States will
will be single and if that prediction
holds it would be the highest percentage
of single working age women in this
country's history by a large margin uh
the economic impacts Morgan Stanley
predicted would be significant Morgan
Stanley quoted one researcher saying
quote we find that single women outspend
the average household shifting spending
policies toward categories most poised
to benefit from the demographic growth
in single women with Rising incomes
those categories include apparel
Automotive entertainment dining
like most research that Consultants
charge millions of dollars to produce
none of that is terribly surprising
women don't get married they tend to
climb the corporate ladder they're
invested more in their jobs when they
earn money that they don't spend on kids
they spend on themselves
but there's one line of the Morgan
Stanley report that stands out it's
Department Stanley specifically urges
its corporate clients to encourage women
to pursue this unmarried materialistic
lifestyle because it'll make the
corporations a lot of money quote for
corporate corporations and investors
that Embrace these Trends there are
numerous benefits from more nuanced
corporate governance and performance to
bottom line growth
the Morgan Stanley report and several
others like it put all the big brands on
notice that they should take a proactive
role in ensuring that more women become
career driven instead of getting married
and having kids
and predictably over the past few years
we've seen various initiatives along
those lines Facebook Apple other big
tech companies have begun offering to
freeze the eggs of female employees
which is not for any medical reason
they're offering it purely so that women
don't get pregnant and don't take
maternity leave and can spend more time
on the clock many companies have also
started paying for out-of-state
abortions
and all that has been widely reported
what hasn't been covered is the extent
to which influencers and celebrities
most of them beholden to these larger
corporations are now openly campaigning
all at once for women to remain single
or to become single again if they made
the mistake of getting married and you
could choose to believe this is all an
accident or that it's coordinated
whatever the case it's clearly happening
there have never been more famous people
telling young women to stop making
commitments to men
so for example you may have seen this
recent video from the actress and model
Emily Ratajkowski and she has around 2.6
million followers on Tick Tock where she
posts videos telling random couples that
their relationships won't last
encouraging women to dress like
prostitutes on Halloween you know
content like that in her latest video
she extolls the benefits of getting
divorced by the age of 30 so that women
can party and have fun while they're
still young and beautiful watch
so it seems that a lot of ladies are
getting divorced
before they turn 30 and as someone who
got married at 26 has been separated for
a little over a year
32 I have to tell you
I don't think there's anything better if
being in your 20s is the trenches there
is nothing better than being in your 30s
still being hot maybe having a little
bit of your own money figuring out what
you want to do with your life everything
and having tried that married fantasy
and realizing that it's maybe not all
it's cracked up to be and then you've
got your whole life still ahead of you
um so for all of those people who are
stressed or feeling stressed about that
about being divorced like it's a it's
it's good congratulations
congratulations
congratulations congratulations for uh
failing at something and not just
failing at something but failing at it
so quickly you're divorced by 30 which
means no matter when you got married
it's it's you you failed at it very
quickly so congratulations for failing
congratulations for abandoning your your
marriage vows for not staying true to
your commitments congratulations it's an
achievement she says
now the caption on that video reads
personally I find it Chic to be divorced
by the age of 30. and it's extremely
popular on the platform more than 130
000 people have liked that video
now this video appears to be a message
of support for Sophie Turner who uh is a
person I didn't know existed but
apparently she does apparently she's a
famous actress who is now getting
divorced from one of the Jonas Brothers
because she felt trapped by marriage and
by motherhood and she wanted to go party
instead and so that's what she's doing
what Emily and Sophie are doing getting
divorced in a very public fashion for a
validly selfish reasons follows a
pattern recently of famous women
advising other women to either stay
single and childless or get divorced
tear their families apart and then act
like they're childless even if they have
children
Maya Khalifa was another one that we
talked about on the show a little while
ago as shocking as it was to hear bad
advice from a porn star uh that's what
we got here's how Maya spoke to her 37
million followers about the importance
of getting divorced multiple times if
possible let's watch that again
oh we're comparing stats baby girl
doesn't know that I am Tom Brady at this
game
married at 18 divorced to 21 second
marriage married at 25 divorced at 28.
third engagement engaged at 29 ended it
at 30 but I kept the ring I'm still
keeping Tom Brady on his toes
we should not be afraid to leave these
men we are not stuck with these people
marriage is not a sanctimonious thing it
is it is paperwork it's something it's
it's it's a commitment you make to
someone but if you feel like
you're not getting anything from that
commitment and you're trying you gotta
go you gotta go you have to go I know
it's difficult to fill out paperwork and
to make appointments and to do all of
these things but this is your life do
you want to be stuck with someone
period
some more great insight there now there
are other examples of this kind of
messaging recently lots of things that
Chelsea Handler publicly spit split from
uh from her boyfriend after about a year
of dating at the time Handler made a
point to explain that quote there was
just some behaviors that we couldn't
agree on and it felt to me like I would
have to abandon myself which maybe I
would have been okay to do if I were 20
or 25 but I wasn't willing to do that
abandon yourself self-sacrifice in other
words self-sacrifice is a Bad Thing
Handler says and she lives by this motto
uh we will give her that encouraging
others to do the same as well she did a
whole Daily Show segment a little while
ago extolling the virtues of being
selfish and childless are you ready to
discover the incredible benefits of a
good night's sleep it's time to awaken
your senses and embrace the importance
of restful Slumber dive into the world
of sleep and introduce yourself to an
amazing product that could revolutionize
your nighttime routine beam dream is a
game changer their dream powder a hot
cocoa designed specifically for Sleep
could transform your nights with flavors
like cinnamon cocoa and chocolate peanut
butter that make it a treat to sip on
before bedtime dream contains a powerful
all-natural blend of ingredients
including magnesium l-theanine
the Indian theanine I think anyway
whatever it is it's good helps you fall
asleep stay asleep and help you wake up
refresh just mix beam dream into hot
water or milk stir a froth and enjoy
before bedtime your body and mind
deserve the gift of restful nights try
beams best-selling dream powder get up
to 40 off for a limited time when you go
to shopbeam.com Walsh and use code walls
to check out that's
shopbeam.com Walsh news code Walsh for
up to 40 off everyone knows I love my
Helix mattress but did you know that
they just launched their newest most
high-end collection Helix Elite Helix
has harnessed years of extensive
mattress expertise to bring their
customers a truly elevated sleep
experience the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for years and I love it
it's the best mattress I've ever had if
you're nervous about buying a mattress
online you don't have to be Helix has a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else go to
Helix sleep dot com slash Walsh take
their two-minute sleep quiz and find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type your mattress will come right to
the door for free plus Helix has a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will they're financing options
and flexible payment plans make it so
that a great night's sleep is never far
away in honor of Labor Day Helix is
offering 25 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for my listeners go to
helixsleep.com Walsh and use code Helix
partner 25. this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now
now at this point you're probably
noticing a theme which is that none of
these women display even emoticum of
interest in sacrificing anything to make
their relationships their marriages in
many cases work out instead they're
adopting without exception what
psychologists call an external locus of
control everything that happens to their
relationship is somebody else's fault
can't possibly be related to them I mean
they can't conceivably do anything that
might Salvage their marriage so they
they move on and they focus on
themselves
not to belabor the point but this is the
message that young people are seeing all
over the place to give one more example
there was also the country star Kelsey
ballerini who talked about leaving her
marriage because the glitter wore off
and it would be a disservice to herself
to stay in the marriage I showed this
clip a few months ago on the show but uh
here it is
is this person right for me like am I
good with this being forever is am I
good with him never doing the dishes
ever in my life you know for the rest of
my life or whatever those stupid things
are how did you know that it wasn't
relationship anxiety or negative
intrusive voices in your head and that
it was actually like your heart speaking
that's a good question
I'm really like intuitive and in tune
with myself and like my gut and my heart
and I think for a while you're right it
was kind of like okay this is just a new
phase of a relationship because
relationships go through Seasons right
and like yes it's not always going to be
rainbows and butterflies like that's
just not it and I and I think for a long
time
I I was like oh this is just
the glitter wears off that's what
happens you know and then you just you
get into a phase where you just you wait
for you wait for it to come back and
then
you know and then sometimes it doesn't
but at the end of the day it is such a
disservice and a dishonoring of yourself
if you know something is not right and
you stay but your life is so loud you
know you have so much going on all the
time
I think when people hear about couples
counseling than they hear about a couple
getting divorced they're like oh it
didn't work but oftentimes that is
actually couples counseling working you
know but like because it you realize
that like this was this isn't the
relationship for both of you and I think
what's so hard is having to break your
own heart and someone else's in the
process of saving yourself
an important thing to keep in mind you
know if if you're wondering again why
I'm so skeptical of uh therapy and
counseling well you just heard it there
you go to couples counseling and then if
you get divorced it means that the
couple's counseling worked because
they're counseling you towards divorce
but you know if there's not enough
glitter then uh what are you supposed to
do just bail go party
whatever you do don't think about
putting in any kind of effort
Hollywood in the media have been pushing
this message for a long time they're
doing it with maximum intensity that's
why I started talking I started the show
yesterday talking about the insane
levels of backlash I received for
criticizing an influencer who promoted
the child free lifestyle as a path to
happiness it was a Relentless barrage of
media coverage all over one tweet that I
made on the subject and that's because
we've talked about yesterday they're
very invested in promoting this
lifestyle which means that anyone who
criticizes it must be furiously dog
piled and shut down
the point is that there's a large-scale
effort underway to convince young people
especially young women but not just
young women to be as shallow and selfish
as possible even if it means abandoning
their marriages and wrecking their
families lots of wealthy people and
Powerful forces are invested in pushing
this message in fact the government is
pursuing it as well the National Bureau
of economic research crunched the
numbers on this last year and they
looked at federal and state taxes along
with benefit programs and they found
that in effect there's a massive
marriage tax in this country people who
decide to get married especially
low-income people end up sacrificing
roughly two years of income to the
government
simply because they got married the
researchers found that quote absent
attacks 13.7 percent more low-income
single families of females rather with
children would marry annually and 7.5
percent more would be married by age 35.
the researchers also found that the
Affordable Care Act Obamacare imposes a
substantial marriage tax quote unquote
because people who get married stand to
lose a lot of subsidies under that law
now you never hear anyone talk about
this but it's true the government is
punishing people who want to get married
especially low-income people it should
be the opposite
incentivizing marriage rewarding you for
getting married and having families but
but uh but that's not what happens in
our country today
and that's a legacy of Barack Obama
that's never mentioned
and of course the current Administration
is continuing what Obama started last
year treasury secretary Janet Yellen
testified uh in a hearing that abortion
is good because it's good for the
economy because it means that more women
are working for large corporations
instead of getting married and raising
kids they could just kill the kid and
then get back to work back into the arms
of their corporate Masters
here she is talking about that
secretary Yellen if the draft of the
Court's majority holding in Roe versus
way is the actual decision what impact
will the loss of abortion access mean
economically for when
well I believe that eliminating the
right of women to make decisions about
when and whether to have children would
have very damaging effects on the
economy and would set women back decades
Roe v Wade in access to reproductive
health care including abortion helped
lead to increased labor force
participation
so there it is abortion leads to
increased labor force participation
therefore it's good you know put aside
the fact that aborting tens of millions
of children certainly shrinks the labor
force over time not to mention you know
amounts to a holocaust to human beings
on a scale previously unknown to mankind
so no matter how it affects the economy
it is evil on its face fundamentally
still that's the treasury secretary of
the United States saying that women
should kill their children and pursue a
career at some soulless Fortune 500
company because in her estimation it
will boost the GDP
there's no doubt that some of the videos
we began the show with uh today are are
just women who are rationalizing their
own self-destructive choices but it's a
mistake to dismiss what we're seeing as
just the idle narcissism of a few famous
ditzy women on Tick Tock there are
forces that profit immensely by creating
a society full of self-centered
automotons who seek connection and
fulfillment from pop culture and social
media and uh and all of that rather than
family life
and these forces include Morgan
Stanley's clients as well as the federal
government I mean the most powerful
forces in the country literally
what are the consequences for regular
Americans well for women it's not great
it used to be that you could say this
publicly it used to be conventional
wisdom that it's bad to encourage women
to be single
this is a Harvard Business Review
analysis from 2002 quote at midlife
between a third and a half of all
successful career women in the United
States do not have children in fact 33
percent of such women in the 41-55 age
bracket are childless and that figure
Rises to 42 percent in Corporate America
these women have not chosen to remain
childless the vast majority in fact
yearn for children indeed some have gone
to extraordinary lengths to bring a baby
into their lives they subject themselves
to complex medical procedures shell out
tens of thousands of dollars and derail
their careers mostly to no avail because
these efforts come too late in the words
of one senior manager the typical high
achieving woman childless at midlife has
not made a choice but a creeping
non-choice
now two decades later that creeping
non-choice has been rebranded as a
positive you can never get any article
remotely like that one published in the
Harvard Business Review today
as disastrous as this transformation has
been for women's happiness and
fulfillment it's probably even worse for
men as we've discussed on the show men
are now using more drugs killing
themselves more than they ever have in
recorded history
and and these are rates also that far
exceed what we find with women and we
shouldn't be surprised by that would all
of society reorients to promote girl
bosses and to demean the institution of
marriage yes women make more money in
the short term
men also have fewer opportunities to
start families and fewer opportunities
to make a living
now in polite company you're not
supposed to say any of this you're not
supposed to think about the
ramifications of the social engineering
that's underway in this country
but whether it's acceptable to point it
out or not none of this is an accident
from every angle women are being told
that the key to happiness is being
narcissistic
selfish abandoning marriage abandoning
their families
at the same time men are being told that
simply by virtue of their gender they're
members of a patriarchy that needs to be
destroyed
that is as destructive a combination as
there possibly could be
in both cases for men and women the
power centers are saying essentially
you're just a passive Observer you know
women are being told that if their
marriage isn't appealing then they don't
have to do anything about it they should
just leave
men are being told that no matter what
they do they're sexist bigots
this passive approach this total denial
of personal responsibility is
unsustainable
as we're seeing again and again
no marriage can survive it and that's
now abundantly clear
and what we'll soon find out if this
continues is that no civilization can
survive it either
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts